>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Steven Livingston: Eliezer
Sternberg admits that he's a little
like that loveable, but
pain in the butt kid
who always has another question.
When his parents would give
him an answer he would be quick
to say, "But why?"
This inquiring mind led
him into neuroscience
and he's now a neurologist
at Yale New Haven Hospital
and you still can't seem to stop
asking bigger and bigger questions.
Sometimes the questions show
up in the titles of his books
like this one for his first book
"Are You a Machine?; The Brain,
the Mind, and what it
Means to be Human."
Sternberg explores the big questions
posed by our brains and our minds,
questions of identity, the
unconscious and the self.
His next book "My Brain Made
Me Do It" took on the question
of whether we are truly
in control of our actions.
Now in his latest book
"Neurologic" Sternberg insists
that our neurons display
a kind of logic
that helps the brain make sense
of the confusion all around us.
As he puts it, the brain assembles
all of our thoughts and perceptions
into a sensible narrative,
a narrative that becomes our life
experience and sense of self.
There is he says, an
underlying neurologic
that drives our experience
of the world.
Questions are bound in this book.
Each chapter has a
whim sickle title,
a question that suggests
something far deeper.
Chapter 2 for instance,
"Can Zombies Drive to Work?"
Chapter 5, "Why Do People
Believe in Alien Abductions?"
Sternberg pushes beyond
the everyday discussions
of biology and neuroscience.
As our Washington Post
reviewer said,
he extends into the more abstract
humanistic even poetic realm
of the philosophy of the mind.
Now, for some answers to these
questions, please join me
in welcoming Eliezer Sternberg.
[ Applause ]
>> Eliezer Sternberg: Hi, can
everybody hear me in the back okay?
Good. I'm really-really
excited to be here,
thank you all so much for coming.
I'm very excited to talk to you
about my new book "Neurologic"
and rather than go into detail right
now and tell you what it's about,
I thought I'd rather
show you a few examples.
Has anybody ever seen this
show, "My Strange Addiction"?
Nobody wants to admit it.
A few people.
So, in short, it's a television show
about people to eat strange things
and I want to show you
a couple of scenes.
This is a woman who eats dirt, so I
tried to have a few close-ups there
so you see the dirt
going into the mouth,
so you know what I'm talking about.
And I wanted to start with
the following question.
Why would anyone eat dirt?
Can you think of an adjective to
describe someone who eats dirt?
[ Background Conversations ]
Right, crazy is the number one
word that probably comes to mind,
but what if I can give you a better
explanation for why she eats dirt.
Would still call this person crazy
if I gave you the following
explanation,
there was a sniper rifle
pointed at her and they said
if you don't eat this dirt I'm
going to gun you down, so then
and so understand why
she ate the dirt.
She was coerced, right?
Now what if I give you a medical
explanation for why she eats dirt?
Would that convince you?
Pica syndrome is a syndrome
of eating odd substances
and there's some examples
in here, paper, paint, ice,
plaster, and dirt would qualify.
Pica syndrome occurs in
people who have anemia
or low red blood cell counts from
a number of different reasons,
but it's from a mineral deficiency
so iron deficiency,
mineral deficiency.
So that's interesting.
Someone's got a mineral
deficiency and this can drive them
to eat very strange substances.
So in the literature
on this syndrome people wonder
could there be some kind
of unconscious motivation
to replenish those lost metals
basically, that lost iron
by finding it in alternative
sources.
And thought of that way, you
might even say that someone
who eats dirt isn't crazy but it's
just sort of a logical compensation
of their brain, there's
an inherit logic to it
and that's the basic idea.
So I want to talk about
a more neurological case
of a patient named Walter
and I can't actually show
you what Walter looks
like because we have privacy
laws in medicine, so you'll have
to take this image to help imagine
him and Walter's wife was really
into the "Antiques Roadshow" and
she saw this on television and had
to buy one just like it and
one day, Walter was walking
around his living room and
he knocks over the table upon
which this beautiful vase
stood and it did not end well.
And Walter's wife was furious,
absolutely beside herself
because this wasn't the first time
Walter had done something like this.
For the past few months, in fact,
Walter had been walking into walls,
knocking over things, and
she just couldn't understand
and this was the last straw.
"Walter", she said, "we're going to
go and take you to the neurologist."
This is a colleague of mine.
So the neurologist decides to
get a scan of Walter's brain
and he gets the CAT scan,
these are just two slices
of a CAT scan I'm just going
to orient you to the bottom
of the screen which
represents the back of the brain
and that is the occipital
lobe which controls vision.
And if you can see it on this
image, there's sort of a darker area
on both sides we call a hypodensity
and that represents a stroke
and on the other side, that
stroke actually extends
into the parietal lobe.
Now, the occipital
lobe controls vision;
both sides of it have been
completely obliterated by a stroke
which means that Walter is blind.
Not blind from an eye problem,
but blind from a brain
problem, he's cortically blind.
The odd thing is, this has
been going on for so long,
why didn't Walter seek out help?
Why would he deny this?
And the neurologist
decides to investigate it.
"How are you?"
he asks. "Fine."
"Anything wrong with you?'
"Nope, everything's perfect."
"Anything wrong with your vision?"
"No, works fine."
The neurologist holds
up a pen and he asks,
"Then can you tell me what this is?"
"Dark, it's so dark in here
nobody can see anything."
The neurologist humors him, puts on
the light, he says "I put the light
on can you now see
what I have here?"
"Look, I don't want to
play games with you."
"Fair enough, but can
you describe how I look?"
"Sure you are a small, fat chap."
Now the neurologist who was tall
and thin, he realizes at this moment
that Walter's not denying
that he's blind.
He actually doesn't realize it.
Now, I wonder is Walter just crazy
for not realizing that he's blind
or can we find a logical
explanation?
Walter has Anton's syndrome which
is a triad of three symptoms.
The first is cortical blindness,
blindness from a brain cause.
The second is anosognosia
which translate
to in English, denial of illness.
So he's denying his, that he's
blind and denying not consciously
but rather unconsciously.
And the third is confabulation,
confabulation is a
fascinating symptom
in which people have this
unconscious compulsion to cover
up any gaps in their knowledge
with a made-up explanation
and they will do this time
after time no matter
how many times you ask.
Now if remember in that CAT
scan the stroke extended
from the visual cortex in the back
of the brain the occipital
into the parietal lobe.
The parietal lobe is actually
also involved in vision,
but at a higher level of processing.
Meaning, if the occipital lobe
is processing the actual pixels
that we see, the parietal lobe is
actually monitoring how the visual
system is working and then using
that to sort of draw conclusions
about it and give more
cognitive input.
Now, imagine a circumstance in
which there was a break in the link
between vision and in the system
that monitors how the
visual system is working.
In that situation, that
very unlikely situation,
you could actually
destroy the visual system
but the brain wouldn't know it
because the monitoring
capacity is not there.
Now, imagine what the brain has
to go through at this moment.
The brain's got to come
up with an explanation
for the following scenario;
my visual system is
working, yet I can't see.
It must be dark in here, right?
This happens to us all the time.
Anyone who is sighted, anyone
who has the ability to see,
yet can't see anything it's
usually because it's too dark
or there's some kind of obstruction.
So the brain confabulates out
of thin air an explanation
for Walter's blindness that
actually makes a whole ton
of sense considering the
brain itself doesn't know
that the visual system is destroyed.
It's neurological, that's a pun.
Okay, so each chapter of the book
and though this part
is the pitch, right?
So is a question that addresses
these sorts of issues and some
of them are what do the
blind see when they dream?
Can your imagination make
you a better athlete?
Why do schizophrenics hear voices?
Why can't split personalities
wear prescription glasses?
Some of those.
Does anyone want to
choose one to talk about?
Yeah.
>> Number seven, someone can't
be hypnotized to commit murder
but only if they [inaudible].
>> Eliezer Sternberg: Oh.
Well I'm not going to tell
you what the actual answer is,
but that's an interesting thought.
We're going to talk about this one,
because it's the only
prepared [brief laughter].
So, we're going to talk
about auditory hallucinations
and schizophrenia.
This is Brandon, he is a patient
with schizophrenia
that's actually Brad Pitt.
But we'll just say
his name is Brandon.
So Brandon was a very,
well-educated guy.
He was in his 30s, went
to Cornell University,
had you know a real charm to
him, but had a very serious case
of schizophrenia and we had
the following conversation.
I said, "Do you ever hear
voices in your head?"
"All the time", he says.
"Usually I hear them, I
hear him when I'm alone
but sometimes he talks
to me at other times.
It gets better when I
scream at him to shut up.
Sometimes he can't talk
if I interrupt him."
"Who do you mean by him?"
"Gerald, he's such an asshole.
He works for the FBI.
He spies on me all the time.
He knows everything.
It happened when I was a kid you
know when he put the spy chip
in my brain, but the doctors
here say that don't see
on it on their brain scans."
"Can you hear him now?"
"Yes."
"What does he say?"
"He's talking about you."
"What's he saying about me?"
"The devil.
He sees the devil in your eyes."
That's the first time I've ever
been mistaken for the devil.
I have been compared to Jafar
from, never the devil though.
So, Brandon mentions a
couple of concepts here.
He has this voice and it's
completely real to him.
He has a name, has a profession.
He had put a spy chip in his brain
and it's somehow associated
with the devil.
And people with schizophrenia
who have these kinds
of auditory hallucinations often
come up with explanations sort
of in this vain and the
question that we're going to deal
with for the rest of this
talk is is this just crazy
as we might be tempted
to say from the outside,
or can we find a logical
reason or a logical explanation
for why the voices are there
and why they say what they say?
To preference things,
schizophrenia is very complicated.
It has a lot of different facets
and we will not be
addressing them all here
and it's also a very poorly
understood disease, so the,
all the great seekers of
schizophrenia will not be revealed.
Maybe, maybe one though.
So here are some the symptoms.
So on the top left, is disorganized
thinking making connections
between ideas that a healthy
brain might never make.
The top right illustrates paranoia.
The bottom left is the
symptom of thought insertion.
The feeling that someone has
inserted thoughts into your brain,
into your mind and they're
not of your own makings.
The bottom right is a similar
one called thought broadcasting.
This is a sensation that all your
thoughts are being heard by everyone
around you and center at the bottom
is the symptom that we're going
to be discussing of
auditory hallucinations.
Anyone think that this animation
looks just like Steven Tylor?
[ Laughter ]
So this is a huge building we're
in and I want you to imagine
that you are walking into the
building and you have instructions
to get to a certain conference room,
and the instructions read "Proceed
down the second hallway to the
left, go through the double doors,
and take elevator C to the
fifth floor suite 511."
So, as you're sitting there
before your morning coffee
and you're trying to picture in your
mind what second to the left means,
somebody taps you on the
shoulder and says, "Hey,
you know elevator C is over there."
So what just happened?
You were thinking very deeply
about what I said on the card
and then accidentally you
broadcast your thoughts out loud
and that's called subvocal speech.
When we think really-really hard
about something, once in a while,
there's very gentle activation of
the vocal musculature which can lead
to unintended vocalization.
So, subvocal speech
is very quiet mumbling
that we all do this very quiet
mumbling, but it's only been studied
since you know the late 40s-50s
and it started to be studied
with EMG or electromyography.
Electromyography is a
technique that neurologists use
that measures muscle activation
by putting a probe on muscle
and it measures voltage waves.
So, physiologist Lewis Gould
[assumed spelling] he took two sets
of patients, half of them
with auditory hallucinations
and schizophrenia and half of them
without them, control subjects.
And he used EMG to measure
their vocal musculature
to see what it was doing
during auditory hallucinations.
And what he found is that 86%
of hallucinating patients had
activation of their vocal muscles
as compared to 10% of the patients
who are not having hallucinations.
So Gould asked the
following question;
could auditory hallucinations
be subvocal speech?
That when someone is hearing a voice
it's actually just their own very
quiet mumbling just somehow
getting into their heads,
really-really getting to them.
So then he asked another question,
he said "If that were true,
if auditory hallucinations are very
quiet, unintended mumbling and what
if he amplified that sound?
What if he made it louder?
Could we hear the voices
in people's heads?
So, in an experimental
set it looks something
like what you see on
the image there.
He plays sound amplifiers up
to the throats of patients
who had auditory hallucinations
and then he waited by a microphone
and then when a patient had auditory
hallucination, a voice actually came
out of the microphone
as a soft whisper.
And the whisper said, "If you're
in this mind you come out of there,
but if you're not in
this mind, you won't come
out there, you want to stay there."
"Who said that", he asks.
And the patient who
name was Roy says,
or she said "I said
that said the whisper.
Are you talking to
yourself ", Gould asked.
Roy, "No I don't" and
then he looks to himself
and the says, "What is it?"
"Mind your own business
darling", says the whisper.
"I don't want him to
know what I was doing."
See that recess, I spoke to
her to ask what she was doing
and she said mind your business.
And this is the first
time we've ever heard an
auditory hallucination.
So, if that's true, if you believe
what these studies are getting at,
that patients with schizophrenia are
really hearing their own voice just
their own sort of unattended
mumbling, then that should
in itself give us a way to stop it.
We can only speak one
voice at time, right?
So, if the voice you're trying
to get rid of is your voice,
then you should audibly
vocalize your own voice
and that should prevent
the hallucination
for coming if that's true, right?
So they did this study
that looked at the duration
of auditory hallucinations
where the intervention was one
of these things keeping one's mouth
open, biting your tongue humming
which is using your own
voice, making a fist
or raising you eyebrows,
so when you go
down on the graph that's a
reduction in the duration
of the auditory hallucinations
and you can see
that humming actually improved the
duration of auditory hallucinations;
decreased their length by about 60%
and this lends support of the idea
that when patients are
hearing voices in their heads,
the voice they hear is their own.
But everybody mumbles
that's the problem,
everybody has this subvocal
speech, everyone in this room
so how come we don't hear them
as auditory hallucinations?
This study tried to look at
that, again comparing patients
with auditory hallucinations
and patients without them.
Each person in this study
wore a headset with headphones
and a speaker and everyone would
of sort of speak a passage into it
and then it would be routed
back into the headphones
and they would basically be
listening to their own voices,
but voice was first
sent into a distorter
and the distorter can make
three levels of change.
The first being, no change so you
speak, goes back into your ear
and you hear your voice
unadulterated;
second scenario some distortion
and the third scenario severe
distortion very-very difficult
to recognize and then they
compared what the two groups thought
and they could push a
button to identify what
that voice sounded like; self, it's
my voice, other, a foreign voice,
a hallucination or unknown
I really just can't tell.
And here's what they found.
So the [inaudible] the percentage
of errors so the patient with,
the patients with hallucinations
clearly had far more errors
in identifying the voice was their
own even with no distortion at all
and far more with moderate
distortion
and far-far more with
severe distortion.
They could pick out what was
familiar about their own voices
because their distortions kept
some of the intrinsic cadences
of the voice, but there's
something about schizophrenia
that they were unable to
recognize their own voices.
But why? Why can't they recognize
and what's stopping them?
And oddly enough, the answer
to this comes from research
on a very peculiar species of fish
called the mormyrid electric fish
and it communicated with other fish
by using electrical impulses called
EODs, or electric organ discharges
and this is a cartoon showing
two fish in a courtship
that isn't working out because
there are so many different voltages
and that's actually true that,
you know, certain fish respond
to different types of
electrical impulses.
And Curtis Bell did the following
study; he wanted to why some fish,
how fish recognized their own
signals versus other signals.
Because when you, when they would
fire this electrical discharge this
form of communication, it's not
like a laser-directed signal
that you know pointed the fish they
wanted to talk to, it's like ripples
on a pond so every receptor in
range is going to pick-up on signal
that includes their own receptors.
So from now on when I say, EOD,
electrical organ discharge,
I want you think fishes'
voice and every time I hear,
every time I say electroreceptor
or receptor I want you
to think fishes' ears because
this is a form of communication
and this is used study
communication in human beings too.
So what Curtis Bell found is
that the way the fish distinguished
their own signals from those
of other is through something
called the command signal.
And every time I say
"command signal"
from now one you'll think intention.
It's the intention to talk
just as each of us know
when we're about to speak.
The fish knows it's contending to
speak because it's bringing fires
from something called the command
signal, the command to speak.
So there you can see
the fishes' brain
which you can always recognize a
fishes' brain by the tail and fins.
And the fish says I want to fire
the EOD, I would like to talk
to the firer command signal,
the command signal goes
to the electrical organ which is
basically the fishes' speech muscles
and then I fires the EOD, it talks.
So now we're going to
study the ear of the fish.
So the next few slides are just
on the electroreceptor itself.
This is what the receptor sees.
Whenever the receptor hears a signal
from another fish you see
a big spike of voltage
on this probe that Bell used.
So he tried this long experiment.
He took his own zapper and
the zapped an electroreceptor,
he sent his own mating
call to the fish and low
and behold it detected the stimulus
and he said, "A, the fish hears me."
Then he put more electrodes
on the fish's brain
and he identified the
command signal.
He found exactly when the fish
was intending to speak itself
and then 4 milliseconds or within
4 milliseconds after that intent
to speak, he fired an electro
impulse at the fish's ears,
at the receptor and this time, the
receptors detected nothing as if
to say, the fish intended to speak
and then heard but ignored it.
So for some reason the fish a
mechanism built into its circuitry,
into its brain and whenever it
hears a signal within milliseconds
of intending to send
that signal it ignores it
as if to say, I said that.
I'm not going to make
a big deal about it.
So, how does it dampen that signal?
How does it sort of nullify
the effect on its receptor?
It's not that, it has to
do with sort of the physics
of the electrical signals.
The represents a sort of a
positive wave, this is it's hearing
in electrical form of
communication from another fish,
but if the fish intended to speak
and that 4 millisecond window was
respected, a second signal is sent
to nullify the first because
it is in the opposite direction
and they cancel each other out
and this has been demonstrated
in the literature.
So that's the system.
Electric fish distinguish their own
speech, their own electrical firings
from those of others by having
a prediction of what it's going
to sound like, the negative one
and if it matches the positive one,
and they cancel out and the fish
concludes that was me speaking.
So that nullification
signal, that prediction
of what the signal is
going to feel like is known
in the animal literature as the
corollary discharge which is a sort
of a confusing concept, but
I'm going to summarize it
for you this way; it's the predicted
sensory result of a motor act.
For example, if I want to raise my
arm my brain predicts how my sensory
system is going to feel when
I do that and so when I do it,
the actual sensation feels
like the predicted experience
and because they match, the
brain draws the conclusion
that I myself initiated
the act and so I don't feel
like someone else moved it.
I feel like I moved it.
So it's the system for matching
experience to expectations.
It's been found in a lot
of different animals.
For example, songbirds use it
to distinguish their own songs
from those of other birds.
Crickets use it to distinguish
their chirps from other chirps
and this is sort of how we
think the whole system works,
so it starts from the brain.
The brain sends the command signal,
the intention to fire,
the intention to speak.
Simultaneously it alerts the
sensory system, I'm about to fire.
I'm intending to talk.
This is what it's going to feel like
and that feeling is called
the corollary discharge.
So then, the fish fires,
the prediction goes out
and then they go to comparator.
This comparator function decides,
is the predicted experience
the same as the actual?
If so they're a match.
If they match, it dampens the signal
and the nervous system relaxes
that it's a self-generated signal.
If they don't match, then the
fish concludes that signal
that I intended to fire does not
match the one that I'm hearing
so the one that I'm hearing
must be someone else's signal.
And the same thing is thought
to happen in schizophrenia
and basically in all speech.
So in our brain we have a motor
command to speak that goes
to the muscles of speech and at the
same time, there is a prediction
of what the voice is
going to sound like.
And then at the same
moment we hear our voice
and then the brain compares,
there's a sound of my voice,
does the sound I just heard
match the way my voice usually
sounds like?
If not, it's not my voice.
If so, it is.
Now, what if there were a
problem with comparison function?
What if every time you heard your
own voice the brain incorrectly gave
you the mismatch signal and you
weren't able to recognize it?
You wouldn't think
it was your voice.
You would think it was that of
someone else, so that's sort
of the basic premise, the basic part
of the argument as to why people
with schizophrenia can't
recognize their own voice,
but there's a problem.
If this is all about
voices then what
about schizophrenia in the deaf?
Do they have auditory hallucinations
even though they can't hear their
own voice?
And the answer is they do have
auditory hallucinations in a sense.
So this is an example of a
patient who has schizophrenia
and has been deaf since before
age 2, so basically as far
as we can remember and this
is a little blurb about him;
he says he claims to
have seen Jesus.
He often hears a voice
communicating to him from London.
When asked how he as a deaf
person could hear someone
from London he replies that
he can see the arms and hands
of the purple, excuse me of
the person signing to him,
so auditory hallucinations
in the deaf consist
of hallucinating sign language.
Now this poses a problem
for the theory, right?
If auditory hallucinations
are all misinterpretations
or the brain misjudging
their own voices,
not recognizing your own
voices, then what explains this?
So we have to extend
the theory it's not
that patients can't
recognize their own voices,
they also can't recognize
their own thoughts.
This is Syd Barrett who was a
member of Pink Floyd and, you know,
at a certain point in his life
he started having odd behaviors
and though he was never officially
diagnosed, it's long thought
that he suffered from schizophrenia.
There's some stories
in his biography
that detail the odd behavior.
One example that comes to mind is
he locked his girlfriend in a room
for days and sort of slipped
her food under the door
and there was also some tell-tale
signs in some of his song lyrics,
so this is an excerpt
from a song called
"Jugband Blue" that
Syd Barrett wrote.
I'll read it to you.
"It's awfully considerate
of you to think of me here
And I'm much obliged to you for
making it clear That I'm not here.
And I never knew the
moon could be so big
And I never knew the moon could
be so blue And I'm grateful
that you threw away my old shoes
And brought me here instead dressed
in red And I'm wondering who
could be writing this song."
So if you led any credence
to song lyrics
that this might be an
expression of his in some way.
He's claiming that
he can't recognize
that he's the one who
wrote these lyrics.
His entire creative process
of putting the song together,
the products of his own mind
he is unable to recognize.
And that relates to another
syndrome of schizophrenia
that I mentioned earlier
briefly thought insertion.
So this is an example of thought
insertion from an actual patient.
"I cry. Tears roll down my
cheeks and I look unhappy
but inside I have a cold anger
because they are using me
in this way and it is not
me who is unhappy but they
who are projecting
unhappiness onto my brain.
They project upon me laughter for
no reason and you have no idea
of how terrible it is to laugh and
look happy and no it is not you,
but their emotions unable to
recognize one's own thoughts.
So how far does this problem
of self-recognition go?
And here we can bring in the
well-known literature on tickling.
The NIH apparently
funds this literature
which is amazing, but it works.
So, here's the summary
of the tickling research.
They have a tickling
robot which is controlled
by the user with a joystick.
So imagine with your right
hand you have the joystick
and you can move it
in all directions
and that controls the operation
of a tickle finger which is a,
like a big sharp thing and
that tickles the opposite hand.
Okay, so they did this
research in 3 scenarios;
scenario 1 is the movement of
the joystick perfectly correlates
with the movement of the
robotic tickle finger,
so when you move the joystick
up the tickle finger goes up
and tickles the other hand.
That turned out not be very
tickly and the correct word is
"tickly" this took me probably
two weeks to figure out.
Ticklish is the propensity to be
tickled, so if you are ticklish
that means you're able to be
tickled but tickly is the magnitude
of the sensation, just to clarify.
So, scenario 2 is that the
joystick moves in the one direction
and then the tickle finger
moves in the same direction
but after a delay of a few seconds.
So you move the joystick
up a few seconds as
and then the finger tickles
you hand in the same pattern.
Now it's a little more tickly
and in the final scenario,
the movement of the
joystick had nothing to do
with what the tickle
finger was doing,
so you could move the joystick up
and then the tickle finger
would do its own thing
and that was very tickly, okay?
So, that's interesting.
So now we know why we
can't tickle ourselves.
The reason is when you intend
to tickle yourself, your body,
you brain has a sensory prediction
of what that tickle is going
to feel like, so if I take
my fingers and I rake them
across my ribcage just like that,
my brain predicts that sensation
and then when the actual
sensation I feel when I do,
when I do that motion
matches the prediction,
they cancel out the brain sort
of nullifies the signal
and makes it not tickly.
Because the nature of being tickled
is that it's an unexpected sensation
so when you can predict it,
when someone else does it
to you the brain doesn't nullify
this rather you feel the entire
sensation and it can
be very exciting.
And so again it seems like the
corollary discharge theory,
the same explanation for why we
can't tickle ourselves can relate
to why we can distinguish our
own voice from those of others.
So now for the big-big connection,
why did I even bring this up?
Can patients with schizophrenia
tickle themselves?
So let me set the stage,
again, right?
We, none of us generally can tickle
ourselves but if we had a problem
in self-recognition and inability
to recognize the intension to tickle
and the consequent inability
to nullify the sensory
signal then we should be able
to tickle ourselves and that turns
out to be true, so there was a study
and I swear this is true of
patients with schizophrenia
and in controlled patients where
they had them tickle themselves
and had other people tickle them
and patients with, and they had a,
I swear this is true, had like
a tickling; tickly rating scale
and they like put a number on it
and it turned out that patients
with schizophrenia are the
only group that's been studied
at least has been able to
reliably tickle themselves.
So, getting back we talked
about a couple of things
that that patient Brandon
mentioned to me
in our conversation, so the voice.
That it's named Gerald.
It has a profession,
it works for the FBI,
spy chip in the brain and the devil.
You know, you might see someone
like this on the street corner sort
of raving about these things and
probably 99.9% or people who pass
that person say that person
is crazy for crazy things.
But can we come up
another explanation?
The brain in the case of
auditory hallucinations has
to explain the following;
it hears a voice
and it doesn't recognize the voice.
That voice has access
into consciousness.
That voice has an intimate knowledge
of the patient's memories, beliefs,
fears, weaknesses, everything
about them this voice knows
everything about them.
And this voice for some reason
has a motive to spy on them.
So what explanation can a brain put
in this circumstance come
up with to explain that?
And I can think of 3 explanations
that have some symbolism sense.
The first is that the
voice was generated
by a text-savvy organization
or like the CIA or the FBI,
because they have technology.
They can infiltrate your mind.
They can spy on you and through
that spying they can learn
everything about you.
Aliens or supernatural beings
so if you are the kind of person
who has those, you know, who maybe
wondered and actually as I talk
about it the book people
who believe in aliens are,
it's a very common belief
among everybody just
in the general population.
So if that's a kind of belief
that you maybe predisposed to
and then you hear this voice that's
a natural place for the mind to go
and finally, divine
their religious entities
so God, angels, and the devil.
So, a lot of people are religious
and even if you're not religious
and had this kind of experience
where you heard a voice
and this voice is not yours.
Your brain cannot recognize
it no matter what you do,
no matter how hard you try to deny
it, the voice is in your mind.
It knows you and it
got in there somehow.
And thought of this way,
I think that these explanations
actually probably the best
that a brain can do in
these circumstances,
so I wouldn't call
them crazy I would say
that under the circumstances they're
actually logical, neurological.
So the 3 different disorders that
we talked about are pica syndrome,
Anton's syndrome and schizophrenia.
What I argue is that in each
of these 3 cases you see really
"crazy" behaviors, crazy in quotes.
Eating dirt, being blind and
denying it making excuses
or having auditory hallucinations
and claiming they're coming
from the devil or the CIA, each of
these seem so crazy on the surface
but when you look at the underlying
deficits that people are suffering
from in these cases, they
actually are logical forms
of compensation for their deficits.
So what you're seeing
is not the disease.
You're seeing the compensation for
something that is true suffering
and these sorts of cases have
led me to believe that the word
"crazy" itself is sort of a
wastebasket term for everything
that we just don't understand.
You know, like a lot of times you
know as a neurologist we see people
who come in with, you know, profound
psychiatric symptoms, you know,
people who are normal one minute
and then the next minute
they're you know throwing things,
they're throwing fits, they're just
acting completely insane and then
when we do the appropriate testing
we find out that they have sort
of an autoimmune condition that
is sort of affecting the brain
and those are very serious.
They end up in the ICU
when we have to treat them
with very powerful medications
and nobody thinks they're crazy,
people will say "Wow, that's
just the progression of disease."
And I think that a
lot of things today
that we don't have an
explanation for are sort of lumped
into the category of crazy.
I think that as the brain sciences
and brain research progresses,
we'll learn about the underlying
deficits that those sorts
of behaviors are compensating for
and maybe we'll stop using the word
"crazy" and we'll just talk
about the actual disease process.
Thanks.
[ Applause ]
Happy to take any questions
anybody has.
>> You can ask me a question.
>> So I just want to well
kind of two questions,
so first will be is practical
application of this what you said
in treatment of patients
with schizophrenia
because that's sounds really
groundbreaking and also
if this is all coming from people's
own heads why there's so many,
I mean because most of
the time we hear about it
that somebody committed a
crime like a murder claiming
that oh voices made me do that.
Like so there is this some kind
of like maliciousness in our minds
that we kind of subconsciously
want to hurt other people?
>> Eliezer Sternberg:
Great question.
So, there are two parts that
is I'll address them in turn.
The first question was
clinical applications.
They're in development so you know
one clinical application was trying
to use sort of suppression
of speech like in that sort
of humming example, but again,
it's if it affects your thoughts
also that's kind of difficult.
I think that in sort of the
therapy, the therapy that's sort
of talked therapeutic
aspects for psychotherapy one
that can be drawn attention to.
The problem is that in severe cases
of schizophrenia that's really
insufficient and there's no way
that you can give someone insight
in sort of those severe cases.
So it's a work in progress.
In the meantime, that
you still require sort
of the classical medications.
The second part of your
question remind me was.
>> Why was like people
usually do terrible things.
>> Eliezer Sternberg: Right.
>> Because of the voices?
>> Eliezer Sternberg: Well, you know
when people commit horrific crimes
it's pretty typical for someone
to say, oh that person is crazy
when that's not necessarily true.
If they have, you know,
anybody crazy I think they mean
like they have some kind
of psychiatric diagnosis
and again that's just
not always true.
Do voices say malicious things?
Absolutely they do.
You know, schizophrenia is
not just an isolated disorder
of auditory hallucinations.
There are a lot of other
components that lead
to very destructive thoughts
and are very painful thoughts.
So, your thoughts are going to be
saying those things and you're going
to hear them as something foreign,
so that's why you can get sort
of command hallucinations to
tell you to do terrible things,
but as you clarify that
doesn't mean that everyone
who commits a crime is having
auditory hallucinations
to tell them to do that.
I don't think that all crimes
should be blamed on sort of problems
with the brain, because
that's not true.
>> In the example you use
with the deaf schizophrenic
who learns sign language.
Did you ever have a case where the
person did not learn sign language,
so how did they get the
information in their heads?
>> Eliezer Sternberg: I've never
had, have never seen that case,
but I would imagine that if
it's a problem with recognitions
of one's own thoughts then the
thought could take any form even
an image.
Our thoughts, every
time we think them,
we feel some kind of
ownership of them.
It's an inevitable, but it's
like oh I thought of that.
But you can imagine a situation
that even if you have no language
but you still have thought, which
is actually debated in literature,
can people really think if
they have no form on language?
That aside, you can have
images, you can have impulses,
and you can interpret
those as being foreign.
Yes.
>> So, the idea that if you
can condition your brain
like couldn't you condition
a schizophrenic
to recognize these thoughts as
their own with the proper ideas
and so plant it into their
head to make them realize
that it's caused by schizophrenia?
>> Eliezer Sternberg: Everything
in medicine is about severity.
So, in very mild cases
you can and that goes for,
so a lot of things you know in
very mild depression, you know,
you may not need medication,
but in and similarly
in very mild schizophrenia you might
be able to give someone insight
into that but in very
severe cases you can't.
You have to think of it
as the brain you know,
it's as clear as day to that person.
Just as it is as clear to you that
you're hearing your own voice,
is that it's clear to
them that they are not.
And it would be like someone
trying to talk you out of believing
that you're hearing your own voice.
>> I think us here today.
Now, I have a small question.
I'm from India and we, I believe
that I'm from the land of the Holy
and we have the biggest
neurological or treatment
for mad people in the world.
It's in Bengaluru City and I know
we see there the [inaudible] valley
of India just like in California.
So, who do you think has the
best authority in the world,
is there some structure in the world
to say, hey it's enough is enough,
do not lie and you know the doctor
or the one the of the collaborators
who are doing bad things
that they better watch out
and whatever they need to do
in terms of taking care of
and chaperoning the whole world,
of course they are, you know,
they should be doing that I totally
respect that, but other than that,
the bottom you know the [inaudible]
or you know sponges or whatever
that they are benefiting, is
benefiting from collaboration
from [inaudible] like
voodoo to hypnosis and all
that so are they aware of that or
please educate us on how much is
under control by the godly
people, I should say, you know,
I know they're not God
but for us the [inaudible]
because when I have trouble
or if I have a brother who's
mentally ill how much I,
pain I go through and you can't kill
him but we have to take care of him
and I've seen families that they
have to take care of their son
or husband or wife or you
know what I mean 24 hours?
So I'm like, you know what is going
on and we have so much knowledge now
that why don't they do some
kind mediation and moderation
as to you know rather than just
kind of you know selling the iPhones
or you know the Smartphones and
the Apple iPhones this and that.
So, please educate us on that
do we need to worry too much
that each individual of this
citizen and me being a citizen
of this great country I feel that
I have much more access, power,
knowledge, freedom to do something
rather than somebody in Ethiopia
or somebody in Sudan or somebody
in Haiti or you know or Jamaica
or whatever and I'm from, again,
I'm a political refugee [inaudible],
but from I'm so grateful just
like I'm grateful to this country
that I'm from the land
of Holy in India.
I know in Silicon Valley in
California it's all Indians, right?
Okay, thank you so much.
>> Eliezer Sternberg: So if I
understand what you're asking,
I would say that in terms of
how much control do we have
of certain disorders I
think again it's sort of a,
there is sort of a communication
between, you know, patients
and families that can
sort of help in recovery.
There's a communication between
doctors and patients that can help
in recovery and it has to be done
in sort of the proper setting
with medications and, you
know, families of patients
with these disorders should
sort of go the doctor visits
and have insight into
the disease itself
and that way hopefully they
can sort of help in the recover
and help in the dialogue.
I'm told that we're out
of time for questions,
but I'm happy to take
someone on the side over here.
Thanks so much again.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.